A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. On the 4th of March 2008, Julian Buckwald took his girlfriend, Carolyn Watson,
清凉的水花将触及你的心灵深处。那些强劲的蓝色波浪可以推动你向前，也可以抚慰你的心灵。从密歇根海岸到密歇根海岸。只需感受当下的流动。让那些浩瀚的湖泊、河流和小溪创造永恒的记忆。在纯粹的密歇根纵身跃入，让清泉洗涤你的身心。在 Michigan.org 保持新鲜感。2008年3月4日，朱利安·巴克沃尔德带着他的女友卡罗琳·沃森，
for a picnic lunch tour waterfall located on a remote property in Budgery, Country, Victoria. The days soon turned into a nightmare when Julian and Carolyn were abducted by a master attacker. It wasn't long before Julian's mother located a frightening note from a satanic cult claiming responsibility for the abduction and threatening to kill both Julian and Carolyn, both of whom were devout Christians. This sparked a frantic, widespread search. Would Julian and Carolyn be found alive? Was this really the work of a satanic cult? Or was there something even more sinister going on?
前往维多利亚州巴杰里偏远地区的一处瀑布进行野餐午餐之旅。然而当朱利安和卡罗琳遭到一名蒙面袭击者的绑架时，这段日子很快变成了一场噩梦。没过多久，朱利安的母亲就找到了一张来自撒旦邪教的可怕便条，他们宣称对绑架事件负责，并威胁要杀死朱利安和卡罗琳，而两人都是虔诚的基督徒。这引发了一场疯狂且大规模的搜寻。朱利安和卡罗琳能活着被找到吗？这真的是撒旦邪教的所作所为吗？还是背后有更邪恶的事情在发生？
Music Julian Buckwald was 22 years old. He was from Budgery, a small country town in the Latrobe Valley in Victoria. About 160 kilometers, which is about 100 miles southeast of Melbourne. Carolyn Watson was 17 years old. She lived nearby to Julian in the town of Churchill, also in the Latrobe Valley of Victoria. They were both small country towns and both Julian and Carolyn still live with their parents. On the 4th of March 2008, Julian and Carolyn had organised to go on a picnic at Julian's parents' property in Budgery.
音乐。朱利安·巴克沃尔德现年22岁。他来自维多利亚州拉特罗布山谷的小乡镇巴杰里。距离墨尔本东南约160公里，也就是大约100英里。卡罗琳·沃森17岁。她住在朱利安家附近的丘吉尔镇，同样位于维多利亚州的拉特罗布山谷。这两个都是小乡镇，朱利安和卡罗琳都和父母住在一起。2008年3月4日，朱利安和卡罗琳相约去朱利安父母在巴杰里的房产进行野餐。
The property was a rural, remote area, mostly bushland. It covered an area of about 500 hectares, which is about 5 kilometers squared or around 2 miles squared. So it's a pretty large area. Julian and Carolyn planned to visit a waterfall that was on the property to have their lunch together. Julian picked Carolyn up in the morning in his 99 gold-coloured four-wheel drive Nissan Patrol, and they left for the waterfall. They planned to be back around 3pm that afternoon. They took only basic clothing and only the food and drink they needed for lunch. Before they arrived at the waterfall, Julian stopped the car to check out the carcass of a dead animal he had seen.
这处房产是一个偏远的乡村地区，主要是灌木林。它占地约500公顷，相当于大约5平方公里或2平方英里左右。所以这是一个相当大的区域。朱利安和卡罗琳计划去房产内的一个瀑布一起吃午饭。朱利安早上开着他那辆99年的金色四驱日产途乐（Nissan Patrol）接上卡罗琳，然后出发去瀑布。他们计划在当天下午3点左右回来。他们只带了基础的衣物以及午餐所需的食物和饮料。在到达瀑布之前，朱利安停下车去查看他看到的一具动物尸体。
So he stops the car and tells Carolyn he will be back in a few minutes. He had stopped the car a little up the road from the carcass, so he had to walk back a short distance and he was out of sight from Carolyn. As he kneels down to check out the carcass, the nightmare begins. He is footsteps running up behind him and he feels a hard blow to the back of his head, and he goes out cold, knocked unconscious. While this is happening, Carolyn remains waiting in the car. After about 5-10 minutes, she starts getting a little concerned. It wasn't unusual for Julian to stop the car and get out to look at various things dead animals included, but he usually was pretty quick about it. He didn't usually take this long.
于是他停下车，告诉卡罗琳他几分钟就回来。他把车停在离尸体稍微远一点的路上，所以他得步行一小段距离，而且卡罗琳看不到他。当他跪下来查看尸体时，噩梦开始了。他听到身后有跑步的脚步声，接着后脑勺遭到沉重一击，然后他就失去了知觉，被打晕了过去。与此同时，卡罗琳留在车里等待。大约5到10分钟后，她开始有点担心。朱利安停车下来查看各种东西（包括动物尸体）并不罕见，但他通常动作很快。他平时不会花这么长时间。
Carolyn starts to think about getting out of the car to go and look for Julian when a person catches her eye in the side mirror. A person dressed in black, wearing gloves and a balaclava is charging towards the car. Carolyn screams, but before she can think about locking herself in the car, the attacker has the door open and drags her out. Carolyn gets thrown to the ground hard. The attacker doesn't waste any time. He immediately hog ties her and covers her mouth with duct tape. He then picks her up and throws her into the back seat of the car. A little while later, the attacker gets into the driver's seat and starts driving away. Carolyn was beyond terrified. She assumes the worse, thinking she's about to be raped and murdered.
卡罗琳刚想下车去找朱利安，眼角余光就在侧视镜里瞥见了一个人。一个全身穿黑衣、戴着手套和巴拉克拉瓦头套的人正朝车子冲过来。卡罗琳尖叫起来，但她还没来得及把车门反锁，袭击者就已经拉开车门把她拽了出去. 卡罗琳重重地摔在地上。袭击者没有浪费时间。他立刻把她五花大绑，并用强力胶带封住她的嘴。接着他把她抱起来扔进汽车后座。过了一会儿，袭击者坐上驾驶座开始开车离开。卡罗琳吓坏了。她做最坏的打算，以为自己马上就要被强奸和谋杀。
After several hours of driving, the attacker eventually stops. Carolyn was dragged out of the car and thrown to the ground. Her mouth was still duct tape shut so she couldn't scream. She was still hog tied so she couldn't move. And then she heard the sound that made her certain her life was about to end. Julian and Carolyn obviously didn't arrive home at 3pm. It was out of character for them to be late. Julian's mother starts to worry and starts pacing around, walking up the driveway to see if there's any sign of them coming up the road. And that's when she sees it. A bottle stuck through their wire fence with a piece of paper hanging out.
经过几个小时的车程，袭击者终于停了下来。卡罗琳被拖出车外扔在地上。她的嘴仍然被胶带封住，所以她无法尖叫。她依然被五花大绑，动弹不得。然后，她听到了那个让她确信生命即将结束的声音。朱利安和卡罗琳显然没有在下午3点回家。迟归不符合他们的性格。朱利安的母亲开始担心，在屋里踱步，走到车道上查看路上有没有他们回来的迹象。就在那时，她看到了那个东西。一个插在铁丝网栅栏上、挂着一张纸条的瓶子。
Julian's mother quickly opened up the piece of paper and she nearly fainted. The piece of paper read and there's a language warning here. Your bloody couldn't leave us alone so your son and girl won't walk about. You get Carolyn and Julian back when we finish our business in the area but only if you behave yourself and don't shit us around again. Tell everyone they are on holiday. Don't you dare talk to the cops again and you'll get your kids back. Shit us again and you never see them again because we'll fuck the girl to death and burn her alive. The bloody boy will really enjoy the torture and sacrifice to our God to pay back 180 times the hurts he did to us when we picked him up. This is your last warning. Do what we say and the kids come back in a live condition.
朱利安的母亲赶紧打开纸条，差点晕倒。纸条上写着（此处包含粗俗语言）：你们这帮混蛋别想甩开我们，所以你儿子和那女孩回不去了。等我们在当地办完事，你就能把卡罗琳和朱利安接回去，但前提是你们老实点，别再戏弄我们。告诉所有人他们在度假。你敢再报警试试，你就能找回你的孩子。再敢戏弄我们，你们就永远别想再见到他们，因为我们会把那女孩操死并活活烧死。那个混蛋男孩会非常享受这种折磨，并把它作为献给我们神的祭品，以180倍的痛苦来偿还他上次招惹我们时给我们带来的伤害。这是你们最后一次警告。按我们说的做，孩子们就能活生生地回来。
Julian's mother is obviously terrified and distraught. She immediately calls the police. I didn't get too more serious than this. The police were on high alert straight away. They organised a large search operation by both land and by air. It wasn't an easy search. Not only was there a large area they had to cover, it was also very tricky terrain. It's remote bushland with a huge amount of dirt roads, hidden roads, side roads and extensive off-road thick bush area. It was a hard search made harder by the fact the pressure was on. It sounded like Carolyn and Julian were in the hands of complete psychopaths. While the search was being conducted, detectives got to work trying to find out who was responsible and what their motive was.
朱利安的母亲显然吓坏了，心烦意乱。她立刻报了警。事情已经不能再严重了。警方立刻进入高度戒备状态。他们组织了海陆空大规模搜寻行动。搜寻并不容易。不仅搜寻面积巨大，地形也非常棘手。那是偏远的灌木林，有着大量的泥土路、隐藏的小路、支路以及大面积的越野密林。由于时间紧迫，搜寻变得更加艰难。听起来卡罗琳和朱利安落入了一群彻头彻尾的精神病患者手中。在搜寻进行的同时，侦探们开始着手查明谁是幕后黑手以及他们的动机是什么。
The note indicates there was some kind of prior history between the kidnappers and the Buckwild family. But not to the Buckwild's knowledge. They couldn't make any sense of the letter or the threats. They hadn't had trouble with anyone. But when interviewing Carolyn's parents, they were shocked to find out they had gotten a threatening letter from the same person about 10 days earlier. The letter said words to the effect of mind your own business and stay away or it will make your life a bloody misery and destroy you and your family. It also says Christians are their enemies. Carolyn's father found it left on their front porch one morning and reported it to local police. However, nothing was done. It was chalked up to be a sick prank at the time. Carolyn's father immediately recognised it was from the same person as it had the same writing and also the same symbol that was on the letter found at the Buckwild's.
便条表明绑架者和巴克沃尔德家族之间存在某种过往纠葛。但巴克沃尔德一家对此一无所知。他们完全无法理解这封信或威胁。他们跟任何人都没有过节。但在走访卡罗琳的父母时，他们震惊地发现，卡罗琳的父母在大约10天前也从同一个人那里收到了一封威胁信。信上的大致意思是少管闲事、离远点，否则会把你们的生活搞得一团糟，并摧毁你和你的家人。信中还说基督徒是他们的敌人。卡罗琳的父亲某天早晨发现这封信被放在他们的前廊上，并向当地警察局报了案。然而，警方什么也没做。当时这被认为是个恶劣的恶作剧。卡罗琳的父亲一眼就认出这封信出自同一个人，因为字迹相同，而且有着与巴克沃尔德家发现的信件相同的标志。
The symbol on both letters gave them a hint as to why Christians were their enemies. It was a satanic symbol. It was the symbol of the ONA, the Order of Nine Angles, a satanic cult known to preach human sacrifice. The letters were very concerning for police and gave them grave fears for Carolyn and Julian's safety. They were both devout Christians, which is why they felt they were targeted by a satanic cult. Police feared they would make good on their threats and conduct a human sacrifice on them. After 48 hours of extensive searching, there was still no trace of Julian or Carolyn. News quickly spread of their disappearance through the local community and their church pastor held constant prayer vigils for their safe return. Police interviewed the pastor to get his take on the satanic cult angle. They felt he might be able to provide some valuable information.
两封信上的标志让他们找到了基督徒为什么是他们敌人的线索。这是一个撒旦标志。它是ONA（九角教团，Order of Nine Angles）的标志，这是一个以鼓吹人祭而闻名的撒旦邪教。这些信件令警方高度关注，并让他们对卡罗琳和朱利安的安全深感担忧。他们都是虔诚的基督徒，这也是为什么他们觉得萨旦邪教将他们作为目标。警方担心邪教会将威胁付诸实践，对他们进行活人祭祀。经过48小时的大规模搜寻，仍然没有朱利安或卡罗琳的踪迹。他们的失踪消息在当地社区迅速传开，他们的教会牧师为他们能够平安归来举行了持续的祈祷守夜活动。警方采访了牧师，想听听他对撒旦邪教角度的看法。他们觉得他或许能提供一些有价值的信息。
What he had to say surprised police. They thought he would be the first to believe in the satanic cult being responsible, but he wasn't. He didn't even believe they were kidnapped. He believed they had just run away together. Through their questioning of the pastor, they learnt that Julian and Carolyn were strict believers in their faith and for that reason the physical side of their relationship had not gotten past holding hands. He had recently had a meeting with a couple and learnt that they had planned to get married, but couldn't just yet because of Carolyn's age. The pastor believed that's what they had done. Run away together to get married. Although we couldn't explain the two notes that were found, the language and vowel nature of the notes was far removed from anything Julian and Carolyn would do. Police started to investigate the possibility that Julian and Carolyn had run away together, but they didn't get very far with it. Remember Julian and Carolyn didn't take any clothes or supplies with them and they only had the food they had packed for their lunch.
他的话让警方大吃一惊。他们本以为他是第一个相信撒旦邪教负有责任的人，但他并没有。他甚至不相信他们被绑架了。他认为他们只是私奔了。通过对牧师的盘问，他们得知朱利安和卡罗琳对他们的信仰有着严格的坚守，正因如此，他们恋爱的亲密程度从未超越过牵手。他最近与这对年轻人开会时得知，他们计划结婚，但由于卡罗琳的年龄原因还无法成婚。牧师相信这就是他们做的事。私奔结婚去了。虽然他无法解释发现的两封纸条，但纸条中的语言和粗俗性质与朱利安和卡罗琳会做的事相去甚远。警方开始调查朱利安和卡罗琳私奔的可能性，但这并没有取得多大进展。请记住，朱利安和卡罗琳没有带任何衣物或物资，他们只有为午餐打包的食物。
Also their bank accounts hadn't been touched. The running away together theory didn't really hold water, especially when you add in the threatening letters that had been received. Police were of the firm belief that Julian and Carolyn had been the victims of foul play. They focused their investigation into the Order of Nine Angles cult. They found the satanic cult was started in England in the 1960s. They had affiliates around the world. The cult advocated a spiritual path in which practitioners were required to isolate themselves from society, commit crimes, embrace political extremism and violence, and carry out a human sacrifice. The problem the police ran into was that they couldn't find any evidence of the cult existing in Australia. They had no reports of anyone being a member of the cult. There were no previous cases on record involving the cult.
而且他们的银行账户也没有动过。私奔的理论根本站不住脚，特别是考虑到收到了威胁信之后。警方坚信朱利安和卡罗琳是不法侵害的受害者。他们将调查重点集中在九角教团邪教上。他们发现这个撒旦邪教于20世纪60年代在英国创立。他们在世界各地都有分支机构。该邪教倡导一种精神道路，要求信徒将自己与社会隔绝、犯罪、拥护政治极端主义和暴力，并进行活人祭祀。警方遇到的问题是，他们找不到该邪教在澳大利亚存在的任何证据。他们没有收到任何人是该邪教成员的报告。没有涉及该邪教的以往案件记录。
There weren't even any rumors or speculation of the cult existing anywhere in the country. This was baffling in their fears that an Australian chapter had just born and they wanted to start off with a bane by conducting a human sacrifice. Almost a week went by and there was still no trace of Julian or Carolyn. The searches had come up empty. There was no sign of them anywhere. The feeling was that the chances of finding them alive were now slim to none. Police switched the focus of the search to finding remains rather than finding them alive. The rugged bushland had extremely hot temperatures in the day but became freezing cold at night. There were snakes and spiders everywhere. Not easy conditions at the best of times, but when you consider Julian and Carolyn had no food or supplies and minimal clothing, the conditions became that much worse. The remote area meant there were no witnesses, so there was no information coming in from the public at all to help the investigation. The only motive police could establish at this stage was the order of Nine Angles cult wanting to commit a human sacrifice.
甚至没有任何关于该邪教在该国任何地方存在的谣言或猜测。这令人匪夷所思，他们担心澳大利亚刚刚诞生了一个分会，并且想通过活人祭祀来一鸣惊人。将近一周过去了，仍然没有朱利安或卡罗琳的踪迹。搜寻一无所获。到处都没有他们的踪迹。大家的感觉是，现在找到他们活着的几率微乎其微。警方将搜寻重点从寻找活人转向了寻找遗体。崎岖的灌木林白天温度极高，但夜晚却寒冷刺骨。到处都是蛇和蜘蛛。在最好的情况下，这些条件也不容易应对，但如果你考虑到朱利安和卡罗琳没有食物或物资且衣着单薄，条件就变得更加糟糕了。偏远的地区意味着没有目击者，因此根本没有任何来自公众的信息来协助调查。警方在这个阶段能够确定的唯一动机是九角教团邪教想要进行活人祭祀。
But given there was no information to suggest the cult even existed in Australia, police started to explore the possibility that the nades were left as a diversion to throw them off the trail of the real abductors. But seven days after their disappearance, when all hope seemed lost and police thought they were looking for bodies, the miracle happened. Julian and Carolyn were found alive. They stumbled out onto the road near the Alpine National Park, hundreds of kilometres away from their picnic destination. They were picked up by a farmer who was driving along the road. They would have stood out, both were in pretty bad shape. They had cuts and bruises and both suffered from bad sunburn. Their bodies were covered in blisters. Detectives wasted no time. They interviewed them straight away. They needed as much information as possible. The attackers were still out there. They thought it very possible other family members of Carolyn or Julian could be at risk. Carolyn is interviewed and details are attacked to police. The attacker dug the hole only a few metres away from her. The attacker then made his way towards Carolyn. He cut her clothing off with a knife, leaving her completely naked and still tied up.
但鉴于没有任何迹象表明该邪教甚至在澳大利亚存在，警方开始探讨另一种可能性：这些纸条是被作为转移视线的烟雾弹留下的，旨在将他们从真正的绑架者身上引开。但在他们失踪七天后，当所有的希望似乎都破灭了、警方以为他们在寻找尸体时，奇迹发生了。朱利安和卡罗琳被发现还活着。他们跌跌撞撞地走到了高山国家公园（Alpine National Park）附近的路上，这里距离他们的野餐目的地有数百公里远。他们被一个开车路过此地的农民救了。他们当时的样子很显眼，两人状况都很糟。他们身上有割伤和瘀伤，并且都遭受了严重的晒伤。他们的身体布满了水泡。侦探们没有浪费时间。他们立刻对他们进行了采访。他们需要尽可能多的信息。袭击者还在外面。他们认为卡罗琳或朱利安的其他家庭成员极有可能面临危险。卡罗琳接受了采访，并向警方讲述了袭击的细节。袭击者在离她只有几米远的地方挖了洞。然后袭击者朝卡罗琳走去。他用刀割破了她的衣服，使她一丝不挂，双手依然被绑着。
She was convinced she was about to be raped, murdered and then buried in the hole. Carolyn does about the only thing she can do. She starts to pray. She prays and prays and prays. And almost as if God himself had shown up to save her, the attacker disappears. She has no idea where he went or what he was doing, but she seemed to be spared for the time being. But she was still tied up and couldn't move. Sometime later she hears a familiar voice, Julian's voice. She cries out, Julian, is that you? He screams back yes. Julian is also tied up and naked and had just woken up after being knocked out. He wiggles his way through the scrub over to Carolyn. He sees a knife laying on the ground next to her, obviously left there by the attacker.
她确信自己马上就要被强奸、谋杀，然后埋进洞里。卡罗琳做了一件她唯一能做的事。她开始祈祷。她不断地祈祷、祈祷、再祈祷。仿佛上帝本人显灵来拯救她一样，袭击者消失了。她不知道他去了哪里或在做什么，但她似乎暂时逃过一劫。然而她仍然被绑着，动弹不得。过了一会儿，她听到一个熟悉的声音，朱利安的声音。她大喊，朱利安，是你吗？他在那边大喊，是的。朱利安也被绑着，一丝不挂，刚从被打晕的状态中醒过来。他在灌木丛中扭动着身体爬向卡罗琳。他看到她旁边地上放着一把刀，显然是袭击者留下的。
He grabs the knife and with Carolyn's help they were able to cut the rope. They stand up and see the attacker had left behind a sleeping bag and a few items of food. They were both terrified. They had no idea where he was, but they could only assume he was coming back at some stage. So they grabbed the sleeping bag and the bits of food and ran off. They were barefoot, naked, battling the extreme heat during the day and the freezing cold at night. They both had cut feet and cuts on their body from the bush. They were both badly sunburnt. And they both wondered if their lives were about to end if the attacker tracked them down. It was a horrific experience.
他抓起刀，在卡罗琳的帮助下，他们割断了绳子。他们站起身，发现袭击者留下了一个睡袋和一些食物。两人都吓坏了。他们不知道他在哪里，但只能假设他迟早会回来。于是他们抓起睡袋和食物逃跑了。他们光着脚，一丝不挂，忍受着白天极端的炎热和夜晚刺骨的寒冷。他们的脚被割伤，身体也被灌木丛划伤。两人都严重晒伤。他们都在想，如果被袭击者追踪到，他们的生命是否会走到尽头。这是一次可怕的经历。
During their ordeal they got a bit disorientated and ended up back near the site that they had escaped from. This was bad as it meant the attacker was probably nearby, but they got lucky. While they were checking out the site, Julian spots the backpack that they had taken with them the day of the picnic. He runs over and gets it and they are in luck. Their clothing is inside. Julian runs back to Caroline with the backpack and they are able to clothe themselves. They stumble around the bush for another few days before lucking out and finding the road where they were picked up by the farmer. Luckily the attacker never caught up with them again. It was important that police identify the site where they escaped from.
在遭遇磨难的过程中，他们迷失了方向，最终回到了他们逃跑的地点附近。这很糟糕，因为这意味着袭击者可能就在附近，但他们很幸运。当他们查看现场时，朱利安发现了他们在野餐那天随身携带的背包。他跑过去拿起了它，他们真走运。他们的衣服就在里面。朱利安带着背包跑回卡罗琳身边，他们得以穿上衣服。他们在灌木丛中跌跌撞撞地又走了几天，直到幸运地找到了那条路，并在那里遇到了搭救他们的农民。幸运的是，袭击者再也没有追上他们。警方识别出他们逃跑的现场至关重要。
There would be a lot of evidence there which could help them track down whoever was responsible. Police conducted an extensive search of the bush area around where Caroline and Julian were found and they got lucky. They found the site. They found bits of rope and items of clothing. They also found the knife, the shovel and the duct tape. They had a lot of evidence. Not only that, they were able to identify the person that owned all of those items. It was great news, albeit somewhat confusing news and it posed a lot more questions than answers. Because the owner of those items was Julian. Something didn't add up. As far as police could tell, the attacker didn't bring any of his own equipment to use.
那里会有很多证据，可以帮助他们追踪幕后黑手。警方对发现卡罗琳和朱利安的地点周围的灌木丛进行了广泛搜查，他们很幸运。他们找到了现场。他们找到了几段绳索和一些衣物。他们还找到了那把刀、铁锹和强力胶带。他们掌握了大量证据。不仅如此，他们还确认了拥有所有这些物品的人。这是个好消息，虽然多少有些令人困惑，并且引发了比答案更多的问题。因为这些物品的所有者正是朱利安。有些事情不对劲。据警方所知，袭击者并没有带自己的任何装备。
He used all of Julian's stuff. But how did he get it? There was another problem. Julian had described to police how he was whacked over the head by the attacker knocking him unconscious. Then he doesn't remember anything till he woke up naked, tied up in the bush. But the mark on Julian's head from where he had been struck was hardly visible. They didn't really match up with his story being hit hard and knocked out. Police start to wonder if Julian was somehow involved in his own kidnapping. Detectives let Julian know his story wasn't adding up. They were upfront with him. They basically told him his story was full of shit.
他用的全是朱利安的东西。但他是怎么拿到的呢？还有一个问题。朱利安向警方描述了他是如何被袭击者击中头部并失去知觉的。然后他不记得任何事情了，直到他醒来时赤身裸体、被绑在灌木丛中。但是，朱利安头部被打的地方留下的印记几乎看不见。这与他被重击并打晕的说法并不相符。警方开始怀疑朱利安是否以某种方式参与了他自己的绑架。侦探们让朱利安知道他的说法说不通。他们对他也直言不讳。他们基本上告诉他，他的故事满口胡言。
They told him to tell them the truth. And he eventually cracked. The evidence exposed his lies. He knew it was all over. He made full admissions to police that he orchestrated the whole attack. He was the sole person responsible for Caroline's kidnapping, faking his own kidnapping in the process. Julian tells detectives everything. He points out the spot where he stashed all of his supplies. He had pre-planned the attack. He had buried a map and the other supplies that he needed such as the shovel, knife, rope and duct tape. He lied about seeing the dead animal carcass. He used that time to change and disguise himself as a kidnapper. He tied Caroline up and then drove six hours north to the remote Alpine National Park area.
他们叫他说出真相。他最终崩溃了。证据暴露了他的谎言。他知道一切都结束了。他向警方全盘招认，供认他策划了整起袭击。他是卡罗琳绑架案的唯一策划者，并在过程中伪造了自身的绑架。朱利安向侦探们交代了一切。他指出了他藏匿所有物资的地点。他事先精心策划了这场袭击。他埋了一张地图以及其他需要的物资，例如铁锹、刀子、绳子和强力胶带。他撒谎说看到了动物尸体。他利用这段时间换衣服并把自己伪装成绑架者。他绑了卡罗琳，然后向北驱车六小时来到偏远的高山国家公园地区。
So no wonder the police search failed. They had no hope of finding them. They weren't searching anywhere near there. Julian chillingly recounts how Caroline was begging him to stop, saying please don't do this, pleading for a life. He describes how he cut off her clothes and dug the hole. He then details how he took his own clothes off and tied himself up and how he started calling out to Caroline a while later to make her look like he had been attacked as well. So police had them in. But why the hell would anybody want to kidnap their girlfriend and stage their own kidnapping? What reason could possibly exist for Julian to do that? The reason is Julian staged the whole thing to try and have sex with Caroline and to get her to marry him. Throughout the entire ordeal Julian was in Caroline's ear saying that they had to have sex to keep warm at night and for that reason it wouldn't be wrong in the eyes of God.
难怪警察的搜寻以失败告终。他们根本没有希望找到他们。他们搜寻的地方离那里十万八千里。朱利安令人毛骨悚然地讲述了卡罗琳是如何哀求他住手、说着请不要这样、恳求饶她一命的。他描述了他是如何割破她的衣服并挖洞的。然后他详细讲述了他是如何脱掉自己的衣服并将自己绑起来的，以及他是如何过了一会儿开始大声呼喊卡罗琳，好让人觉得他也被袭击了。所以警方抓住了他们。但是，到底为什么会有人想绑架自己的女友并伪造绑架案呢？朱利安这样做到底能有什么理由？原因在于，朱利安策划整件事是为了试图与卡罗琳发生性关系并让她嫁给他。在整个磨难过程中，朱利安一直在卡罗琳耳边唠叨，说他们必须发生性关系来在夜里取暖，因此在上帝眼中这并不是罪过。
But Caroline stuck strong to her faith and refused Julian's advances for sex and refused his marriage proposals. They had planned to get married one day but there was tension between them about the timing. Julian wanted to get married now whereas Caroline wanted to wait until she finished her studies. Plus she wasn't old enough. At no stage was Julian ever lost. He knew exactly where they were the entire time. He just pretended to be lost doesn't excuse to spend more time with Caroline to try and get her to crack and have sex with him. Julian thought he would only need a couple of days. He'd get Caroline to either have sex with him or agree to get married or both. And then they would leave the area. But after a week it became apparent Caroline was having none of it. So he made his way out towards the road to be rescued.
但卡罗琳坚定信仰，拒绝了朱利安的性要求和求婚。他们曾计划有一天结婚，但关于时机问题他们之间存在紧张关系。朱利安想现在就结婚，而卡罗琳想等学业完成再说。况且她还不够法定年龄。朱利安在任何阶段都没有迷路。他自始至终都知道他们在哪里。他只是假装迷路，借此花更多时间与卡罗琳在一起，试图让她崩溃并与他发生性关系。朱利安以为他只需要几天时间。他会让卡罗琳要么与他发生性关系，要么同意结婚，或者两者兼而有之。然后他们就会离开这个地区。但一周过后，很明显卡罗琳根本不吃这一套。于是他朝大路走去，等待被营救。
Julian was charged with unlawfully carrying away against one's will, abduction with intent to marry, abduction for sexual penetration and theft. The court heard that as a result of being hog-tired and left in the back of the vehicle for six hours, Caroline had severe damage to her neck, back and hands. Julian was found guilty at court in 2009 but he wasn't remanded into custody straight away. He was allowed to stay out on bail while awaiting the sentencing hearing. But Julian did want to hang around for his sentencing date. He would have known he was going to get jail time for what he did. So he tried to pull off an escape. He got hold of a fake Indian passport. He dyed his hair and darkened his skin in an attempt to look Indian. It was a ridiculous disguise. But he somehow managed to fool Australian customs because he got out of the country. Thankfully he didn't get very far. He was detained when he landed. His real identity was discovered and he was extradited back to Australia.
朱利安被指控违背他人意愿非法带走、意图结婚的绑架、为性侵犯而进行的绑架以及盗窃。法庭审理得知，由于被五花大绑并被扔在汽车后座六个小时，卡罗琳的颈部、背部和手部受到了严重损伤。朱利安于2009年在法庭上被判有罪，但他并没有立即被还押候审。在等待宣判听证会期间，他被允许保释在外。但朱利安可不想留下来等宣判日期的到来。他很清楚自己所做的事会让他入狱。于是他试图逃跑。他搞到了一本假的印度护照。他把头发染黑，皮肤涂黑，试图让自己看起来像印度人。这是一个荒谬的伪装。但他不知怎么竟然骗过了澳大利亚海关，因为他成功逃出了国境。谢并未逃出多远。他一落地就被拘留了。他的真实身份被发现，随后被引渡回澳大利亚。
His plan was to eventually make his way to Germany where he had relatives. He was laid a sentence to seven years and three months for kidnapping Caroline and he was sentenced to a further six months for skipping bail and leaving the country. He had an unparalleled period of five years and three months, meaning he is eligible for a lease now. And if he isn't out already, it won't be long until he is. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他的计划是最终前往德国，他在那里有亲戚。他因绑架卡罗琳被判处七年零三个月监禁，并因违反保释规定潜逃出境而被判处另外六个月监禁。他的不可假释期为五年零三个月，这意味着他现在符合假释条件。如果他还没出狱的话，离他出狱的日子也不会太远了。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。